so let's see I guess her man had
something to say about this Kiki
Palmer's boyfriend oh shames her for the
outfit she wore to the Usher concert
it's the outfit though dot dot dot
you're a mom this man is being dragged
on the internet for basically asking
please don't wear a thong to an usher
concert now the top comment says get a
new boyfriend sis the idea that once
women give birth only identity they're
allowed to have is Mother and matron it
is so harmful and isolates tons of
mothers to the point that they dead
Emoji people are people as long as they
aren't hurting anyone and she's not let
them be trouble in Paradise already why
are men so jealous of women who are more
successful and popular than them